[FINGER SNAPPING]
[DRUMS AND SNAPPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: And so we
welcome you warmly,
for you are today, and
forever shall be, Princeton's
great Class of 2019.
Welcome to Princeton.
It's great to have you
here. [MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW WEINER: They've
become friends
with people from
other religions,
and then for the
rest of their lives
they can look back and
remember the friendships
that they had with people
who are different from them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JILL DOLAN: We're
really eager to get
a sense of the vast
variety of research
that students do on this
campus in conjunction
with faculty and graduate
students and staff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SIGRID ADRIAENSSENS: It's not
only about engineering,
but it's also about
how the communities
that these structures
are built for adopt
these structures
and live with them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: I am thrilled that
this year's Nobel Prize was
awarded to someone who
is both a great economist
and a great Princetonian.
[MUSIC PLAYING]